هل سبق انثى من سمعتها بالقاعده العجيبه
عشرين عشرين عشرين عشرين وما سر الرقم 20
في انقاص الوزن اختصاصيه التغذيه
والمتحدثه باسم جمعيه الحميه البريطانيه
شرحت الامر فاذا شعرت بعدم الراحه بعد
فتره وجيزه من تناول الطعام او كنت تعاني
من الانتفاخ او تريد المزيد بعد انتهاء من
وجبه جيده فربما تحتاج الى ابطاء في سرعتك
في تناول الطعام هذه القاعده تتلخص في
تناول 20 قطعه طعام بحجم 20 بنتا امدغها
20 مره خذ استراحه لمده عشرين ثانيه بين
لقمان وخذ 20 دقيقه لتناول الوجبات هناك
عده طرق يمكنك من خلالها ابطاء وزير
التناول الطعام على الفور مثل ضبط عداد
الوقت عند تناول الطعام او عند تناول
الوجبات لتكوين فكره عن المده التي
تستغرقها لتناولها التخلص من عوامل
التجديد كالتلفاز او الهاتف واجلس على
الطاوله لتناول الطعام بدلا من الاريكه
ايضا خذ وقتا اطول لتناول او وقت اطول
لتناول الطعام هو مجرد احد الطرق التي
يمكنك من خلالها خساره الوزن بامان وتحسن
صحتك العامه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات